hey guys it's Justine and I am so
excited because right now we are getting
a chance to check out the Chevrolet
Corvette e-ray this thing is absolutely
fantastic not only do we have a full
version here but we also have a little
Tearaway one right here so we can
actually get inside and see what it's
all about
[Music]
this is the electric all-wheel drive
Chevrolet Corvette eray the first
Corvette was introduced all the way back
in 1953 and now 70 years later they're
updating it with electric performance
it's one of the only sports cars that
has two separate propulsion systems to
provide naturally aspirated V8 power
with the electrified responsiveness of
electric all-wheel drive it is the
fastest Chevrolet Corvette in history
you can go 0 to 60 miles per hour in 2.5
seconds and a quarter mile in just 10.5
seconds combined it has 655 horsepower
from both the electric and small block
V8 motor hi I'm Erin link I'm the
vehicle performance manager for
Chevrolet Corvette what do we have here
today well Justine this is the brand new
Chevrolet e-ray it's the world's first
electrified Corvette and the world's
first electric all-wheel drive Corvette
in front of us we actually have one
that's kind of a cut down so we can
actually see everything that's going on
inside the vehicle all right we have
this really tall section here to show
how much structure we get out of it and
then the battery pack is four groups of
20 battery cells a piece some of the top
features
features everyday Street mode
a 5 miles per
support all electric driving for a
period of time before the engine turns
on for normal driving moving silently
wow on its own it's yeah completely
silent so orange is positive torque and
green is like regen torque so if I hit
the brakes here
it's going to think about charging if
I'm done with that or I exit
whoa it's gonna start up okay I wasn't
ready for that sorry wow I mean that
sounds incredible if I give a little
blip on the internet oh wow I mean just
to go from stealth to that it's shocking
I mean this is what everyone has been
waiting for it is yeah we didn't lose
the Brilliance of what Corvette means
but we've added something to it that's
pretty special just wow it has a
lightweight lithium ion 12 volt battery
a standard Brembo carbon ceramic brake
system standard Magnetic Ride Control
that has three suspension settings with
staggered 20 and 21 inch wheels with
Michelin Pilot Sport all-season tires
the electric front motor in combination
with the l2t engine gives the e-ray an
invigorating sound this little system is
the battery cooling system so with the
electrification comes three cooling
circuits that aren't there on the normal
Stingray the battery here the powertrain
Electronics up front and then the drive
unit itself up to 45 miles an hour you
can drive in full electric propulsion
mode so it really only charges through
the road yeah no plugs no ports or
anything no cables it basically just
charges by spinning the front axle
should we get in it when we get in it we
sure can oh this is exciting
[Applause]
it's like getting into a spaceship
[Music]
oh wow
we're in you're in among the first to
ever do this much like most newer
Vehicles there are a lot of driver
assist Technologies also built into this
it has Lane keep assists with Lane
departure warning forward Collision
alert and automatic emergency braking
depending on what mode you select that
will determine the amount of electric
assist there's a few selectable modes
like Tor sport track weather my mode and
Z mode there's also a charge Plus
feature which will maximize the
battery's charge there's so many details
like everything is just it's I don't
want to touch anything the gauges here
show engine output and electric output
and so you can measure that in
Horsepower or Torque and then there's a
Dyno feature that's a rolling graph of
two minutes down to 15 seconds of how
much data you'd want to see at once and
then this has some information that we
calculate for you of fuel saved battery
temperature motor temperature there's
also a ton of customization you can
choose from when creating your ideal
e-ray there's four aluminum wheel
finishes 14 exterior color choices
including this sea wolf gray that is
featured here this new 2024 Riptide blue
and cacti you can also choose the e-ray
exclusive body length stripe package in
electric blue my name is Kirk benya I'm
the exterior design manager for Corvette
so let's talk about this design because
obviously it's incredible so what was
kind of like your main focus create a
compelling car you know that defines a
new entry into the marketplace and so
what does this mean for people now that
we can have this extra electric
performance it gives you all-wheel drive
capability really good for pulling the
car through corners accelerating things
like that all-weather driving you know
it puts you at a safer platform this
color is amazing yes yes you even
mentioned there's like kind of like some
gold yeah I got a gold flake in it we've
got our most to grow aggressive carbon
fiber package here which gets your
carbon fiber around the cluster or the
steering wheel the center console the
door inserts on both sides their
Standard carbon flash badging black
exhaust tips and bright fading carbon
fiber ground effects and even carbon
fiber Wheels in carbon flash visible
carbon fiber finish or visible carbon
fiber with a red stripe we use it all
through the exterior as well this is our
Aero package of course you know all
Corvettes are heavily tuned and heavily
designed in Wind tunnels and that for a
high-end Performance top speed
look at all like there's enough storage
there for me you'll see those lights
There's a Zombie RGB light package oh no
you have to get the RGB light package
that allows you to tune the colors of
how you want the engine see
you can see we've got this floating
glass idea here this helps that hot air
get out there the e-rate also introduces
the all-new Artemis dipped interior
which has deep green tones on almost all
of the Interior surfaces and will be
available in all 2024 Corvettes so top
speed 180. that's pretty fast this was
such an incredible experience like I
have been following this car for quite a
while so the fact that I'm sitting here
behind the wheel wouldn't it be so fun
if we could just take it out on the
street right now let's go let's go this
is absolutely beautiful I am such a huge
fan of carbon fiber too look at this oh
look
this car in the vehicle okay this is
what I was worried about like how much
cup holder space are we gonna have
two drinks we're set here's the little
switching wheel that'll take you into
the different modes
heated seat yes please
[Music]
like it has a little home
oh it's so cute well that was it that
was the first look here at the e-ray and
I am so hyped about this I mean I hope
that one day I can take this actually
out for a little drive and test it out
I'm actually kind of speechless like
this is really really freaking cool 180
miles an hour I can't even fathom that
well thanks again for watching if you
guys haven't already please hit
subscribe and like this video and hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos and leave a comment below and let
me know what you think and which color
would you choose okay here we go no keys
push the start oh
okay we gotta try the horn
I don't want them to run out of gas
they're already really low and you can't
just like roll up to a gas station with
this
[Music]